[Music]
this is where we take videos of famous
people and we combine them usually for
no good reason
it kills time first up we've melded John
McCain and Michelle Bachman I am NOT a
Washington DC inside establishment
politician and I never want to be I'm a
real person who did that here life and
that's it I want to take to the White
House
Kris Jenner and the Dalai Lama of course
they just don't baby come soon and I
think a country because of the democracy
the freedom good luck Peter there's an
interesting one Peter Griffin and he man
now although sign of it that's one of
the mysteries the strangest mystery is
my sword it's gone
[Music]
and finally one that actually makes
sense me and Andy it's distracting
[Applause]
if I biggest during the show it just
seems it would be awkward it was just an
awkward format to me I know it seems
kind of cool Rico
[Applause]
good I think the meat it's got your face
is very cool-looking I it's not I don't
exactly like it but I don't dislike it
eat right yeah
it's disconcerting but yeah in a
friendly way I think it's hot